this is the work of ventaja cop he's a
super-smart really brilliant guy he
extended the beach metropolis algorithm
to handle SDS transport better now how
is this possible what I have written
here is the very scientific way stating
what is really happening the most
difficult paths form a manifold in path
space and you can grab this manifold and
sample this exhaustively with an
equation solving system let's take a
look at the intuition this is super
useful but very challenging to
understand and implement for ordinary
people now what is exactly happening
here so we have the diffuse balance this
is xB and we hit the light source after
that which is XC on the upper right and
between the B and the C we have two
specular bounces and imagine that I am
fixing the xB + XC these are two fixed
vertices and if I have this glass egg in
between that is perfectly specular then
I can write an algorithm that computes
what should be the exact outgoing
direction from this diffuse vertex in
order to exactly hit that XC point there
is only one possible path because we
have perfectly specular inter
reflections in between so what should be
this outgoing direction from XP this is
the equation solving system that we are
interested in how do the results look
like well you can compare it to
metropolis light transport that is
either very noisy or it misses some of
the light paths completely in these very
difficult test cases the manifold
exploration part razor outperforms all
of the existing algorithms PSS m LT is
the Callahan's time M LT m LT is the
original feature metropolis one more
example a beach metropolis BER pt I will
tell you in a second what that is C
Kellerman's metropolis light transport
algorithm and D manifold exploration
path tracing
events are was kind enough to put I
think 20 minute talk about this work on
his website so make sure to check it out
it is really well illustrated it is
really well explained make sure to check
it out let's take a look how the
algorithm converges in time take a look
at this beauty
lots of SDS light paths and in the first
ten minutes you already have some degree
of convergence that would take days or
possibly forever with other algorithms
it's pretty amazing pretty amazing one
of my favorites out there here you can
see side-by-side Kellerman's metropolis
light transport versus manifold
exploration part racing
it's difficult not to get excited about
this right